so there hasn't been really a good
opportunity to rerun my interview with
Milo you know polis which took place in
October of 2014 but I think this is as
good a time as any we had this story
last week about a former Milo intern who
killed his own dad and I was super clear
during that interview I don't believe
that Milo you Napoles is in any way
responsible for these horrific actions
that Lane Davis I believe the guy's name
was took against his father but every
time Milo's name comes up I start to get
emails from people saying David you
should really interview Milo you Napoles
I don't believe that Milo and appleís
would be interested in being on the
David Pakman show at this time in fact I
would probably bet money on that and I'm
not a betting man but a lot of people
also don't know that I did interview
Milo innopolis now the context was very
different than his recent all right
fanboy whatever thing that he's had
going on the topic was actually
gamergate and we did sort of address
issues of transgenderism during this
interview but not an interview that a
lot of people have seen the audience is
much bigger now than it was in October
of 2014 so we will do today as our
classic interview my interview with Milo
Yin appleís from just over three years
ago I'm joined today by Milo you nopales
who is an associate editor at Breitbart
the reason that Milo is here is to
follow up on what's I guess yesterday
marked the start of our coverage of
gamergate and to quickly get people up
to speed as to where we are now at least
from the purposes of our show gamergate
is this online movement for lack of a
better term there are those who believe
that gamergate is a kind of a consumer
movement against what some see as fraud
nepotism cronyism within the video game
industry there are others who see
gamergate as a misogynistic and
sometimes even racist or xenophobic
movement designed to keep whether it's
women or minorities or other groups out
of the video game world yesterday i
inner brood via brianna wu who is a
video game developer she made a very
specific allegation about an interview
with milo that did not happen and milo
is here to address that so Milo let's
start at the beginning how did you first
get involved with gamergate
well I wasn't previously a gamer in fact
I'd said some relatively disappointing
things about gamers in the past but I
kind of got sucked into this issue
because I saw if you like a marginalized
community the gaming community being
accused of some things that it obviously
has not done and having its art form
having its Hobby trashed by people who
were obviously in it for ulterior
motives and it's sort of it I guess it
raised my journalistic hackles if you
like as I sort of saw this this
injustice if you want to put it like
that going on and thought I'll take a
look into this and as time has gone by
I've become I guess this sort of default
okay and is your position that you are a
pro or anti on this issue or do you see
yourself I know that you wrote in the
blog post about your interview with
Brianna Wu which didn't happen you wrote
I am a reporter and not a member of the
movement and thus I am well-placed to
bridge the divide between the Pro and
the anti side do you still stand by that
that's your position within gamergate
absolutely and you can see that not only
from the interactions that I have on
both sides of people but also people
have been doing these incredible maps of
the gamergate universe they do this
great number crunching and data and
analysis of the tweets and you'll see
that there are a few of us people who
are able to speak to both sides of this
debate slap-bang in the middle of this
this great sort of connections map
people like Christina Hoff Sommers and
Americans Enterprise Institute and and
me are right in the middle
geographically speaking of both groups
although it's absolutely true that yes I
am very sympathetic talk to the
gamergate side of all of this I'm just
reporter covering story so let's explore
that just in the interest of full
disclosure for my audience that's not
necessarily keyed into the minutiae of
what's going on here there are some
quotes of yours that I'd like to read
back to you and get your reaction to
those in terms of where they place you
kind of on this spectrum you wrote quote
because an army of sociopathic feminist
programmers and campaigners abetted by
achingly politically correct American
tech bloggers are terrorizing the entire
community lying bullying and
their way around the internet for profit
and attention as an outsider to this
when I read that it seems to me very
one-sided it seems very kind of
anti-feminist and and bordering on
patronizing of so-called feminists well
I think is everything wrong
intrinsically with being anti feminist
if if you mean specifically by that that
you have no patience for the sort of
shrieking miss and wrists that represent
the modern feminist movement I think
that anyway any normal person would and
I include myself in this call themselves
inequality feminists call themselves an
equity feminists believe firmly and
passionately that men and women are
completely equal as I believe they've
gays and straights are completely equal
as a gay man you know I don't believe in
discrimination against anybody but too
much of modern feminism I think is is
characterized by man-hating okay and
given that specific caveat I'm perfectly
happy to say I'm not a feminist and it's
it's in that context that that paragraph
is written which I think you'd
understand from the piece so I'm
perfectly happy to stand by that with
that understanding of feminism okay one
more quote and again this is just all
kind of setting the context for looking
at the claims around the interview I
think this is important you use wrote
we're all used to feeling a niggling
suspicion that quote death threats
unquote sent to female agitators aren't
all they're cracked up to be
and indeed there is no evidence that any
violent threat against a prominent
female figure in the media or technology
industry has ever been credible that is
to say that any feminist campaigner on
the receiving end of Internet trolling
has ever been in any real danger
I found that comment well first of all
do you still stand by that I guess
there's no point in talking about it if
you've if you've no longer stood by this
there's a factual claim in there which
is that none of these threats has ever
come to anything that is true it's a
perfectly true factual claim none of
these struts has ever come to anything
there's a factual claim in there there's
no evidence that any of these members
then ever in any real danger I think
that's perfectly fair the thing that you
will probably be objecting to is the
tone of this there seems to be
dismissing what are in some cases very
ugly violent unpleasant threats against
women well it's not so much the tone per
se but it's you know we're talking
really in shades of gray here
right and for example yesterday after I
asked Brianna Wu why did you decide to
publicize the threats you received I was
accused of victim blaming in some way
now I rejected that completely in the
sense that I asked that question out of
sheer personal curiosity when I received
threats authorities have told me don't
publicize these it's kind of feeding the
trolls in a way it can invite copycats
so I think we're dealing in a gray area
do you think though that by writing off
some of the claims you are in a sense
victim blaming no absolutely not what I
think I'm doing is drawing attention to
the fact that the closer you look into
the claims made by some of these
feminist campaigners the less they stand
up to scrutiny I mean one by one the
feminist campaign is around whom a
gamergate controversy centers are having
more and more questions raised about
their reputations and that's not as a
result of some sort of intrusive
misogynistic campaign into their
backgrounds to try and dig dirt up about
them it's as a result of the fact that
many of them are trolls and bullies and
are getting a taste of their own
medicine and I sound like a very harsh
thing to say and I should put a caveat
in here to say nobody endorses threat
rape threats death threats or any kind
of bullying or intimidation on the
Internet well when you say nobody of
course you mean other than the people
doing them I'm guessing those people are
okay with them well who knows depends
depends who's actually doing it because
we don't know this is no no yeah there
isn't there's not a single case in
anywhere in gamergate I've been a
prosecution made so we don't know yet
but the fact is that you know no normal
person is going to say that any of these
threats are acceptable the people
responsible should it be court should be
arrested should be imprisoned for them
but when you look in to some of the
people who claim to have received these
threats and you see
decade-long patterns of dishonesty this
tells me as a reporter that we need to
treat some of their claims with a little
bit more skepticism and a little bit
more journalistic rigor and we shouldn't
simply credulous ly repeat the claims
that they make which have in the past
almost without exception we've proven to
either be false also be
misrepresentations now as a responsible
reporter when I see that in somebody's
biography or s
that in somebody's history however that
information comes to me I am I have a
responsibility to treat that person's
claims with a greater degree of scrutiny
than I would have if they were just some
ordinary person I've never heard of
before that's just a fact that's just a
reality of reporting and you know there
are these feminists one of these
feminists claim to have stabbed somebody
in the face and killed them and not
reversed not reported it to the police I
mean this stuff beggars belief in some
ways that specifically that made that
claim well I can tell you that a
photographer who worked with Zoe Quinn
has made this claim very publicly at the
risk of her at great risk to her own
professional reputation if that turns
out to be a lie I have no reason to
imagine that it is alive spoken to her
even to other people involved in that
it's difficult to find the truth of it
but these sorts of claims float around
these individuals and have done in some
cases for decades
Rihanna woo I'm currently investigating
an allegation that she had a restraining
order taking out her we know that she's
created memes and trolled the gamergate
community we know that she's created
sock puppets making jokes about having
erections of deaths I mean she's she's
sort of admitted on your show yesterday
that she'd made this borough lulz
Twitter account what you didn't do is
read out some of the contents of that
which include tweets like I get an
erection at the death scene in Tomb
Raider but that doesn't make me a
misogynist the sort of twisted damaged
psychology it takes to come up with this
stuff okay so I think in just kind of
sum up the context though I think it
would be fair to say that I guess you do
you were not in any way overstating your
position at the beginning when you said
while you consider yourself a reporter
on this you're certainly very
sympathetic to one side we can agree on
this and I'm mostly sympathetic because
these continual claims some of which are
going to show end up not panning out not
being true that are uncritically
reported by newspapers as grand as the
New York Times are detracting attention
from the real story here which is a
concerted effort to reclaim some some
quality and independence and standards
in video games journalism and every time
gamergate makes some headway in this
another one of these manufactured
scandals emerges and completely
suffocates all of the all of the oxygen
out of the room and leaves no space to
discuss the really serious issues which
are
Triple A game developers paying for
positive no question and that's
something we will be covering in the
future but for the purposes of our
interview here let's see if we can clear
up what are now too drastically
different explanations for what happened
in the interview that was set to take
place between you and Brianna Wu in your
blog post which I've reviewed in detail
several times to summarize and I'll give
you an opportunity to kind of get more
specific
after you believed that an interview was
scheduled with Brianna Wu you were
unable to get a hold of her your
attempts to get a hold of her for the
interview failed and eventually she said
that this was moving too fast and that
while she was willing to do the
interview it wasn't going to happen on
that particular day that's your story
correct like that I think what actually
happened specifically was that she began
to ignore messages from my producer from
my tech ran from me on platforms that
she was otherwise communicating with
other people on she was tweeting
regularly but ignoring our DMS she was
emailing other people but ignoring our
emails you know and this happened
immediately after I sent her a list of
questions that she initially said seven
of them were find then she started to
get cold feet you know I've been in this
business a long time we know what
happens when interview interviewees are
starting to get cold feet they start to
stall the language becomes more vague
they start you know they're reluctant to
make commitments about time and then
eventually they drop off the Raider it's
happened to me many times no question
about it let's pause there the
conclusion to my interview with Milo you
nopales after the break welcome back
let's now continue our classic interview
part two of my interview with Milo you
nopales so I got the list of questions
from you along with Brianna Wu's
comments and as assuming that this has
not been doctored in any way which I
have no reason to believe that it has
been I want to make that clear she was
indeed fine or found the questions fair
to use the language that she used with
the exception of about five or seven
questions as you said now Brianna's
claim on my program yesterday was as
follows quote what happened was he Milo
was frankly beyond rude to me when we
were trying to plan this thing rudeness
is certainly subjective so I don't know
that there's much of an analysis to do
there so let me finish the quote and
then you'll you can respond to what you
find
most important she goes on I want to
remind your viewers I was on the run
from my house I had no internet I was
going to a television station to do
MSNBC and CNN which frankly Trump's his
show referring to Milo's show and then I
was trying to get to a safe location I
had my phone but I was literally driving
to a place that was secure to go do his
show she went on to say I'm also frankly
in trauma because of everything that's
happened to me and what you saw here was
frankly a childish reaction from someone
that didn't understand I was literally
driving to a hotel to get Wi-Fi set up
to do his show and then he just blew up
online and was frankly a jerk about it
let's go piece by piece Milo did but
this is a very convenient fiction but
let's say I I know you don't agree that
it's true but if you allow me to kind of
walk us through the pieces of it maybe
we can figure this out did she
communicate to you that she was looking
for a place to get Wi-Fi and intended on
doing the interview on that day as she
claims no she didn't okay did any
attempts from you or your producer
around the time that the interview was
scheduled to take place where any of
those responded to no they won't
was there any contact after the window
for the interview had elapsed with an
explanation from Brianna as to why the
interview didn't happen no and public
and private DMS and emails continue to
go unanswered while she was responding
to other people and appearing on other
TV shows okay so I mean if speculate
what do you think happened here I think
it's very obvious what happened she
thought that this would be a good
mechanism to publicize herself and her
experiences and what she feels to be an
important issue in the in the gaming
industry
she used the threat which she says was
made against her as a way of propelling
those those views into the mainstream
she thought that my show would provide
her with a platform from which to appear
as though she were open to discussion
and when she realized that I would
actually be a journalist
I'm giving her an easy ride she got cold
feet and she pulled out except she
didn't have the professionalism and the
courtesy to let me know that was
happening she instead strung us along
gave my producer messages saying Oh what
might happen later might happen later oh
it probably won't happen today despite
the fact that I had informed her that it
was that I need that the deadline she'd
agreed to the deadline I had given her
every opportunity to vet the questions
in advance which I never normally do
which you will know is highly irregular
journalistic practice which I did I've
never done it yeah I've never done of
course I mean I've done it once or twice
perhaps ever as an expression of good
faith because I wanted to come on the
show and I want to show that I was
opened to to discussion I was happy even
to sense of my own questions despite the
fact that I knew that some important
things in there would end up not being
asked that I knew that my audience would
want to hear about I told her that if
she bombed out that it would cost us
five six hundred dollars in production
costs but you know for that episode I
told her about deadlines I told all of
these things and she agreed to all these
terms then suddenly she goes quiet just
by appearing on other shows despite to
beating her precise location to the
nearest five meters at a comic
conference at a time when she claims she
was in fear of her life which sounds
very suspicious to me I mean you can
take a view as to whether she was acting
in good faith or oh she's responding to
you honestly when she says that yes
although most people are advised by law
enforcement not to contact the press
when they have serious threats that a as
she claimed on to us today she was never
informed by law enforcement not to
publicize these threats which I don't
believe for a second and B that she
thought that her grand mission of
bringing attention to the terrible
plight of women in the gaming industry
trumped that piece of advice or trumped
that instinct which I don't believe
either I think what happened here is
very obvious she realized she wasn't
gonna get an easy ride and she backed
out unfortunately I was in a situation
where I had no time to book another
guest it cost me money my whole show was
down the pan so I recorded a message
very very plainly and and I mean you
give me her opinion about but I said I
felt very fairly simply reading out the
facts as to what had happened and moved
on I was prepared to leave the situation
there and so she went on-air with you
and why
about me and said that I was dishonest
and I was childish at which point I felt
compelled to respond should be clear so
that the audience understands the reason
Milo is here in this format is because
there were specific claims made
yesterday by Breanna there's one less
thing and we're so out of time but I
feel like one more minute is worth it to
get this question and you know one of
the claims of one side of the gamergate
movement as you know and it's not the
side that that you sympathize with is
that there is some combination of
misogyny and or homophobia and/or racism
within video gaming and you mentioned
being a gay man yourself one of the
issues I've been covering for many years
and I find it to be a serious issue is
that of discrimination within the LGBT
community and specifically that's of
transphobia from gay men and lesbian
women and in researching for this I came
across a September 16th column for
Breitbart London where you published a
piece about Chelsea Manning referring to
Chelsea Manning as a traitorous
transsexual and asking if the government
had cut it off yet referring to Chelsea
Manning's penis this is pretty
disturbing stuff to me separate from
gamergate right totally separate from
gamergate but I I would be remiss not to
bring this up is that something you
stand by well I think you understand
that the context is the most a longer
piece that I wrote would you explain
that I don't think transition surgery is
remotely the right approach for
transsexualism transsexualism is you
know it's a psychiatric disorder it's
not a it's not you know it's not
something that can be responded to do
with with cosmetic surgery which is what
happens now we need to reassess it and
approach it with wigs drops and therapy
now contact to that column was a
provocative Mickey taking column about
somebody who is a convicted traitor some
of the language used in it was very was
very salty and fruity if you're the kind
of person who gets upset by words if
you're the kind of person that listens
to ten minutes of a Joan Rivers set and
wants to smash your television it's not
the kind of thing you're going to like
that's perfectly fine but so about hold
on a second so to be clear Milo I want
to make sure we have
on record accurately here when you
reference Joan Rivers are you saying
that this was a satirical piece I'm
saying that I'm using the same sort of
approach to comedy to ridicule people
who deserve to be taken down a peg or
two
using the same kinds of devices that she
uses yes absolutely I'm saying that okay
because it's weed to me in my opinion is
it didn't read like a satire piece last
thing I want to say about this you
mentioned transsexualism being a mental
disorder the fact that there is
something called gender identity
disorder which is a diagnosed so to
speak in some individuals who feel that
their physical gender does not match the
gender they feel they are that's
different than saying this is equivalent
to psychopathy for example so I think
that you're treading on dangerous ground
we may just disagree on this right this
disease is that it's closer to are
things like there are patients at Johns
Hopkins which is the University Hospital
the pioneer transition surgery they have
a award which deals with a lot of these
sort of related conditions there are
patients who believe that their arms
don't belong to them they wake up one
day and they thing that arm is no longer
part of their own body there are
patients who believe that they are dead
that they wake up and they're clinically
dead the basis of my argument is that
what we don't do is warp reality to
conform to those delusions with those
kinds of disorders we give people
therapy and drugs to help them reconcile
reality with with their minds that's a
very commonly accepted treatment path
for those sorts of disorder my
contention is the transgenderism falls
into that category of disorder okay and
to be clear this is just an assertion
that you're making well it's based on so
it's based on reading the science it's
based on reading a science from from
Johns Hopkins which is the first
University to really pioneer transition
surgery which no longer performs that
surgery because it has a sufficient body
of patients to know that that most of
these people Pro tragically kill
themselves with or without the surgery
and there's some reason to suppose that
people who have the surgery or even more
likely to kill themselves it's a
treatment plan that doesn't work and
it's something that's become a holy cow
because I think the conference
transgender people have been bracketed
in with gays and lesbians as part of the
sort of LGBT civil rights block so we
have
we now wrongly consider transgenderism
to be just the next civil rights
frontier I don't believe it has anything
in common with gays and lesbians
whatsoever I understand that some people
will find that offensive well in the
same way that many people would find it
there's many people who disagree that
the issue of gay and lesbian rights has
anything at all to do with the struggle
for african-american rights in this
country and there people who disagree
so people are on a spectrum on this no
question about it it was that view - I
don't think those people are entirely
wrong I think it's a debate that we
ought to have but for various reasons
we're not really allowed - all right so
listen Milo we're totally out of time I
hope that you feel I've been fair to you
I did my research I've asked the
questions that I think needed to be
asked and do you feel you've been
allowed to give your views yeah I don't
think gaming it would be particularly
desperate no my views on transgender
isn't but otherwise I think we have a
really great view okay thanks for being
on we've been speaking with Milo you
nopales associate editor at Breitbart
thanks again thanks